book called a billion wicked thought
that was written by a bunch of engineers
at Google and they were looking at
billions of search billions of Google
searches and you know there's no
shortage of pornography on the Internet
and there's much less by proportion than
there was when the internet was first
invented and it's so interesting because
it actually turned out that one of the
things that drove the development of the
Internet and the technology was the
proclivity of young men to search out
sexually provocative images that was
what was at the forefront of the
development of the Nets extraordinarily
interesting they were motivated to they
were motivated to use it for that
purpose and that provided the platform
from which it emerged amazing anyways
the Google engineers looked at
pornographic search processes and then
segregated mail searches from female
searches and what they found was that
the male searched out images probably
surprised no one no one considers that
you know particularly interesting but
the female searched out literary
representations of pornography it was
written so I can give you an example of
that if you know about Harlequin
romances does everybody still know about
those anybody not know about those okay
well they're mass-market romances and of
a very stereotypical
type and they're the original ones were
pretty harmless in terms of no violence
and no real sexual contact content but
that was 40 years ago and they
differentiated tremendously and now
there's hardcore Harlequin romances and
with with particularly garish covers and
then there's the old you know more tame
basic sexless and aggression less
romances where everything is implied and
not explicit but the explicit ones exist
so they did a flawed analysis of the
typical pornographic female fantasy well
and it was so so comical because
engineers did this and social scientists
would never do this because they'd be
probably too concerned about the ethics
of it or some damn thing but engineers
you know they'll just plow ahead with no
concern whatsoever for such things and
they actually discover things that way
and so
they discovered the basic plot of the
female pornographic literary product and
they identified so basically what
happened was that a innocent
well-meaning and attractive young woman
encounters a male who's a bit of a
monster and the monster is five types of
classic male monster for all you males
who want to know this is what you can
become vampire that's a good one were
wolf billionaire pirate and surgeon okay
so that's very interesting because well
first of all there's a dominance thing
is it now you're actually blushing you
know you're actually blushing about that
that's very very funny so sorry to point
it out but it was so comical you know I
know I know it's so funny I was reading
this I was reading this it was just
cracking me up I thought oh my god
really
pirate vampire oh that explains it what
about all these damn vampire shows right
they're so popular online they're so
popular on Netflix oh yes and then
there's the were wolf there's nothing
sexier than a were wolf apparently but I
mean so there's predatory don't there's
predatory dominance that's implicit in
that right with the billionaire it's
more abstract but clearly that's an
indication of very high success in the
male dominance hierarchy so but there's
this desire for aggression that's in
that a real aggression right and it's
not surprising to me to me at all it
makes perfect sense but what the basic
plot is that the woman encounters this
mysterious and aggressive male and tames
them that's the female hero myth as far
as I can tell it's beauty and beast and
so it's because well there's no fun in
taming someone who's already tamed and
what makes you think you really want
someone who's pay many ways there's no
interest in that Plus when when when
chaos manifests itself what makes you
think that someone tame is going to be
good for anything and it's a real
question and so that aggression is
absolutely vital it's absolutely
necessary but because it's in court
incredibly dangerous which
of course it is it has to be civilized
and so what happens is that the
archetypal female in these pornographic
romances Sadducees and tames the
aggressive male and that's her encounter
with chaos now it's more it's more
conflict
of course females are more complicated
and that's exactly how it is and it's no
wonder because their their lives are
more complicated but okay